ne dites plus diocèse de versailles mais
dorénavant église catholique des
yvelines une église qui de s'offrir un
visage plus professionnelle en se dotant
d'un nouveau logo une forme de boucle
ouverte entouré de plusieurs triangle de
couleur est à + rue plusieurs couleurs
qui représente la variété la diversité
les contrastes énormes qui existe sur
notre diocèse
urbain pas des rurbains un peu rural
milieux populaires milieu plus plus on
choisit etc
très mélangée
cette nécessité d'un nouveau logo est né
après le synode diocésain il aura fallu
trois mois de travail 1500 euros
dépensés et la constitution d'un panel
de fidèles et de salariés le diocèse
compte 70 collaborateurs
on a réuni des membres de services de
saison depuis une dizaine d'années
présent dans l'évêché des membres de
services diocésains arrivés plus
récemment et puis des membres de ce
qu'on appelle des équipes d'animation
paroissiale dont ils sont des bénévoles
investis au service des paroisses dans
le quotidien et aussi des membres
d'associations de groupes on avait
besoin de mettre en oeuvre une chaîne
graphique comme ça se passe dans toute
entreprise aujourd'hui pour avoir une
communication cohérente donc on a une
charte graphique police à lisieux césar
et ont fait des propositions paroisse
pour que vraiment le message soit encore
plus fort encore plus lisible dans les
yvelines l'église catholique estime à 80
mille le nombre de pratiquants et
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
penser ce n'est pas tant à versailles
qu'on les recensent mais plutôt dans les
quartiers populaires comme aux mureaux
ou attrape au sein des communautés
antillaises et portugaise